old prices for new homes are on the rise  they've been reporting that but there's  a new kind of home  hitting the market that some say could  change that trend look at this  this is a 3d printed home popping up on  the east coast right now  they can be built in a fraction of the  time it takes to build a traditional  home  this one is a three bedroom option in  new york it's listed right now for two  hundred ninety nine  thousand dollars homes of that same size  in that area  are a hundred thousand dollars higher  and often a lot higher than that  the printer though can't do all the work  it can build about forty percent of the  structure  and workers do the rest but even that  forty percent can drastically lower  construction costs  this process can save you about twenty  to thirty percent on an overall build  isn't that crazy so other home builders  are using 3d printers  one company in texas now works with  non-profits to provide  low income housing just kind of blows  your mind